it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines for that we turn
the Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
all right Raymond no commenting on my
voice
um every time Kamala Harris speaks you
can expect something quite entertaining
and disturbing well yeah but now she's
saying the quiet part out loud Laura
listen when we invest in clean energy
and electric vehicles and reduce
population
more of our children can breathe clean
air and drink clean water
reduce the population Laura the Secret
Service may have quit that investigation
of the cocaine bag a little too early
but look it was so bad the White House
had to correct Kamala Harris's speech in
the transcript replacing population with
pollution right this is why this is the
problem she she's a she's a disaster
even among friendly crowds she's at 55
percent disapproval rating Laura you
know you gov poll 53 percent in an LA
Times poll and this inability to
communicate is a big part of the
breakdown in confidence surrounding her
remember Raymond again we go back to the
New York Times in November of 2019 when
she dumped out of the race she quit the
race and they said it was one of like a
paraphrasing but one of the worst
campaigns they'd seen people were
fighting with each other it was just a
disaster that was you know pressaging
things to come and the staff is running
out of that office but then yesterday
the White House dispatches Kamala Harris
to the Rain Coalition push meeting to
salute Jesse Jackson who was supposedly
retiring but decided not to Kamala
celebrated Jackson but not before
mispronouncing Apostolic when thanking
church leaders watch here
an Apostolic Church of God so when I was
in law school I drove a Toyota Corolla
it was a fancy car for me
and I had a bumper sticker in the back
window
Jesse Jackson for president early on he
even had the audacity to name this
Coalition the national rainbow
coalition
think about that
find the rainbow he was one of the first
to define the rainbow Define the rainbow
Laura she gets stuck in a phrase you
know she mistakes frequency for
profundity but even here is she saying
that Jesse Jackson founded the LGBT
movement I don't know what she's saying
but again they keep sending her to these
friendly groups and even among
African-Americans she's at 17
disapproval this is not what Joe Biden
needs at this moment by a long stretch
wait you know I would actually love to
interview Kamala I'm actually inviting
her on the Ingram angle tonight and this
new time slot Raymond which I love by
the way this is great but it would be
fun to have her on and just really
really talk like you know let's just
really like drop everything else let's
just why why are you doing this it's not
your thing go into fashion go not
fashion go into something else her next
big two speeches are to a black sorority
luncheon and a Desiree Rogers fundraiser
you remember her the largest teachers
union I got to get to this the largest
teachers union the Nea just wrapped up
their meeting in Florida which got very
little coverage this was their leader
Becky Pringle laying out the priorities
for the children
we are required to fight for fair and
free elections and a woman's right to
make decisions about her own body this
radical Court
struck yet another blow
against our lgbtq plus community
that actually licenses
discrimination under the First Amendment
Nea
we all descend we all we all descend
we all descent and we will change this
world for our students with that inner
fire burning we will never Bend wait
wait wait wait wait wait oh I I I
that if the Republicans going to want to
win in 2024 just play that speech
Raymond that will win the election this
is what your kids are being subjected to
well France and angry people apparently
what a disaster somebody either needs a
Xanax or an exorcism but it has nothing
to do with our teaching or the reading
scores and math scores that are in the
toilet Laura this is an Abomination and
they give most of their money 50 million
to the Democratic party mostly where are
our kids how do they figure in all of
this she's doing that yeah she's doing
kind of a Max you know Maxine Waters
channeling there too at moments Raymond
great to see you seven years hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else